[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[Music]
this answer the internet is brought to
you by whistle pig whiskey stick around
after for the full detail what's up guys
i'm akar singh and i'm back to answer
more of the internet we got this phone
here and i'm using this because i have
effeminate hands if you could wipe off
one group of people on the earth who
would it be
that's too real
uh
san francisco
san francisco
you're a [ __ ] plague the whole city
looks like i am legend you guys suck the
fact that you pretend you're so liberal
and then you root for nick bosa your
[ __ ] phonies
your [ __ ] frauds just be honest about
who you are you're a city of ugly people
who aren't any better than anybody else
june 30th cops comedy club i'll see you
guys there have you ever seen an
attractive woman in san francisco
you're from san francisco
i gotta [ __ ] take back everything i
said now god damn it
be from oakland
jesus if you go back in time and give
one piece of advice to yourself what it
would it be this is real as [ __ ]
something andrew schultz said to me
years ago he said the moment you are
immune to rejection you are unstoppable
go ask every girl out that you think is
cute and if she says no who gives a [ __ ]
it's actually hilarious that a girl says
you're not good enough to date me it's
so funny
it's great good for you now you know
move on ask another girl she says no who
cares you're fine get rejected fail all
the time and learn from it and the
better you handle the rejection i
remember i was before i met my wife i
wasn't even trying to i was just trying
to like get better at talking to girls i
would get rejected by girls and be so
like unfazed by it and think it was so
funny that sometimes it flipped them it
happened a couple times it was like i
would just be like yeah i get it you
know what i mean or whatever i would
just be as funny as i could with it and
then weirdly it flipped him a couple
times would you rather have one giant
dick for an arm or have all your
freaking fingers be dicks
dude this is tough because have all your
fingers be dicks
you can't
like finger you always wait you could
finger a girl at least but then it's
still just mad baby dicks in her i think
i want one giant dick for an arm but is
it a giant dick for an arm with five
fingers all ten fingers and dicks is
kind of fun
think about how often you're getting
jerked off dude you're putting on a
glove you're basically having sex
you think this through actually this one
is also very easy i am answering a lot
of dick questions what is your ultimate
nightmare social social situation
oh any political rally would be hell on
earth dude anything where people care
about dumb [ __ ]
like like politics and voting and
[ __ ] human rights
[ __ ]
yuck dude
they're gonna take our abortions i know
that sucks but i don't want to talk to
you about it
yeah i mean i'm upset with you but who
wants to talk about it
you're going to go to a march oh my god
a march jesus christ i can't even walk
away from you you're following me
if you had to be noah and noah's ark and
you could only save two people from
earth race who would you say beyonce not
even a question
i'm a bit who's not a big beehive guys
yeah okay you would love taylor swift
too that [ __ ] i leave her on the
[ __ ] island i don't trust her at all
[ __ ] who's the man because it's
somebody that has to procreate with
beyonce and obama and beyonce make some
beautiful ass babies is it obama harvard
educated can dunk i think maybe he's
just black
oh here's the clip i've seen have you
seen the clip where he asked the guy for
one shot and then drains the three and
walks off the court obama that's my guy
obama and beyonce great they're racially
ambiguous it's not even it's great but
look at that what is your stance on
washing your hands after going to the
bathroom gay just super gay to do
super gay to do this hand sanitizer
everywhere bro yeah waste all that time
for it
after pooping i i wash hands after
pooping but after peeing if my hands
have touched my ass i'm washing it so
it's not fully gay to wash your hands
after you poop that's kind of gross
y'all don't but peeing what is pee
it's a dick you've touched a dick
it's your own dick would you rather sit
on a dick and eat a cake or sit on a
cake and eat a dick
is it weird that this isn't even hard
for me i would rather sit on the dick
and eat a cake because at least i get
cake
what if sitting on a dick is like
getting an ice bath you just got to get
used to it and that's not it's kind of
nice it's relaxing maybe what is a
weirder moment for each to see
north american seeing europeans riding
on the ships or the europeans seeing the
native americans living on the land who
thinks it was weirder for the europeans
like
it was mad apocalyptic for the native
americans like this is it's like
watching corona come to your shores
in human form this killed all of them
it's alien invaders though end of the
day and the only thing is columbus was
like i thought we were in india but he
don't know what indians look like you
know what i mean so it's not even that's
definitely a white person asked that
question uh how famous does someone need
to be for their murder to be considered
an assassination oprah is the bar
oprah oprah oprah would be assassinated
dr phil without the assassin no dr phil
got killed on a [ __ ] street you know
i mean he got killed in the back of an
alley buying a [ __ ]
chicago hot dog a guy out of here
son dr phil gonna get killed by his own
heart what are we talking about
uh what would be three examples of your
living hell one example san francisco
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
who is the one white person that black
people would pick in chappelle show
racial draft i absolutely know this
answer tom brady tom brady he doesn't he
doesn't try too hard to be anything that
he's not but he's still the coolest
[ __ ] on earth we'll talk mad
[ __ ] to any person regardless of race
that's the guy dude
i feel like steve nash had a little bit
of that eminem does not eminem is great
at rap but i don't i'm like that's that
cool that's the cool white boy but
that's a white boy brady transcends
all right what's stereotypically
speaking what's the thing all white guys
need to be able to do what about all
black guys asian guys
white guys just need to be comfortable
being white don't try to not be white
don't apologize for being white
don't be too proud of being white that
gets weird but it's okay to be white
it's cool to have a little pride you're
a white guy nothing wrong with that you
know what i mean dude as an indian you
don't know how what people would tell me
yeah people tell me you need to add more
indian i swear i'd be like dude i don't
know how i'm not even trying to be funny
i'd be like there's a way to act black
in america there's a way to act white
there's no way to act indian what do you
[ __ ] want me to do you know i i talk
a little black but my outfits don't
always match so
i you know a little bit from both every
other minority they ask my advice is to
love yourselves and i again for black
people is different because y'all got
systemic [ __ ] but for every minority i
said i don't care about how anybody else
feels about us i care about we feel
about ourselves so white people like
indians good for you i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm i don't care indians gotta like
indians
thank you for watching ati with akash
singh is brought to you by whistle pig
piggyback rye whiskey it is the only six
year age 100 rye whiskey in existence it
is the perfect spice the perfect taste
to come out in a cocktail it's a
bartender's best friend go to whistlebig
whistlebigwhiskey.com or any local store
retailer and get yours right now i
highly recommend it it's very good